I know Wayne Campbell was a character
you played even before Saturday Night
Live
how did Wayne's world come about I was a
heavy-metal kid in the suburbs of
Toronto and thank you thank you
I created the suburbs of Toronto thank
you very much
when I came to New York City I I saw
that you know with Manhattan cable right
next to CNN was the Robin bird show I
don't know if anybody from New York I
did not create the Robin bird show and I
became obsessed with cable access so I I
I wanted to do a cable access show he
did film a bit before I did it on
Canadian TV as well
uh-huh it was called Wayne's power
minute it was on a show called
it's only rock and roll on on the seeb
lauren had thankfully Thank You mr.
Michaels cast me on Sarah alive and we
had our cast together and then Mike came
in and he was the young upstart and
seemed looked about 13 and I was in my
mid-40s at that point and Mike asked me
to be be his sidekick on his sketch
Wayne's World and play this character
and Mike just said Garth loves loves
Wayne he digs him I didn't think they
were going to release the movie I did I
didn't think they liked it the initial
feedback when I handed in the script
Lawrence said that somebody there said I
don't get it it was the note which I've
never forgotten I Arthur and then uh it
was meant to be encouraging yeah no I
and trust me I took it is that you know
it inspired such confidence and when
they called me Lorne called me I was
over the room going oh my god I hope I
can get this gig you know
and Lorne and I had known each other
before I even started Saturday Night
Live the first time I met everybody was
when Lauren asked me to host the very
first time and I'll never forget walking
into the writing room - Mike's writing
room
and Mike saying these two sketches that
I'm thinking of doing one is Wayne's
World and one is sprockets now sprockets
I love Wayne's World I didn't get it all
and and I was like I want to do
sprockets oh we did sprockets Yeah right
and so that was the end and that's when
that's when they dropped the cue cards
right yeah they do they drop the cue
cards Mike and IFIF you 2-bit were in a
two-shot together and they drop the cue
card to Mike because I so it's live TV
and the guy has the cue cards and they
were furiously doing rewrites to the cue
cards on-air and I'm like I like not
long ago I was in government sponsored
housing in Toronto how the hell did I
get here and then he dropped the cards
and they went in every possible
direction
I saw 15 crew guys just diving and
picking up the cards and they were in
the wrong order so if you if you youtube
it it's like and now we come to the
European top five the first one of five
that's 105 as you might imagine not the
fifth one is as follows so then they
were making the movie and I will never
forget this because Lauren called me at
home and said can you come to a lunch or
a dinner with Sherry Lansing as the
president of this studio and John
Goldman to talk about Wayne's I said
Lauren I'm on my way to get married
right now because I just wanted it be
secret out that you did take the call i
Mike and I got to you know have so much
freedom usually you got to do 40 takes
and you know this was just incredibly
cool that we got to have all this
freedom in fact I want to thank Penelope
because a lot of times I would do some
gharst dick like hey over here if you're
going to spew spew into this and
Penelope would say if you can do it ten
seconds faster I can keep it in the
movie the message was faster and funnier
and you remember the time when we we
shot the one thing that Lauren made me
shoot over again was when we were in the
club and you had a knife and you were
no what was it a zest on guys yeah yeah
zapper thing and Lauren pointed out that
you looked a little too aggressive when
you did it in just Penelope you can't do
that because it's not funny if
somebody's a gross I remember that yeah
everyone does that get used to it
Laurens gonna be whole evening of it
yeah and um the scene was good I thought
it was a funny scene but you had put in
my natural laugh as an outtake yeah
would you guys ever find Bugs Bunny
attractive when you've got money you
guys were so tired because it were just
that was the last day of the shoot you
were so tired and you just had to get
back Lauren had a limo waiting outside
for you gonna want go from that scene
into the car anyway God he wasn't
driving
haha never made it yeah but I mean you
were I just let the camera run and you
guys improv didn't you guys made that
scene so funny the scene that there was
no time for is one of the best scenes in
the movie I always loved Queen I thought
it was amazing that this band had a an
operatic song that was like 9 minutes
long and my brain invented their career
I mean it just well I I was afraid that
we were taking a whiz on a Picasso at
that point because it's such an amazing
you know song and when I was a kid
growing up my friend of mine had a dodge
dart swinger that was kind of like our
mirth mobile and when Bohemian Rhapsody
would come on everybody had a Galileo
and if you took somebody's Galileo you
got like slugged you know so that's
that's what I remember what comes from
realized the greatest experience I've
had with that was being in a casino in
France which was like Rick took casino
in France and bond James Bond they and I
had just done something for Her
Majesty's Government yeah I can't really
talk about Oh
let me just say you're welcome
and I was talking to my cufflinks which
was my two-way transmitter I was blowing
up an escalator and the guy who runs the
casino I don't know what they're called
groans chef du casino whatever had seen
me and put on Bohemian Rhapsody and I
got really embarrassed you know I wanted
to get out of there there's a big
escalator going up it was all like super
crazy rich people from Luxembourg and
the Benelux region and here and there
and when the park goes kick again Ganga
I saw 3,000 heads go did dad do with
people with furs and stuff but I was
like wow that's awesome
and I and I was 36 at the time so doing
that for four hours I still have a sore
neck brutal yeah it was brutal
I was I was learning a lot as well I
mean they were learning how to make
movies that I knew but I was learning
how to be professionally funny and and
you know that's that's something that
you know takes takes a lot of time but I
had great masters to learn from he never
ate lunch that was the weird thing he
just did bicep diddle to the shirt off I
never get much obviously never be - a
sinner can be like eating my own hand
and he'd be going you eat lunch I was
ripped underneath that t-shirt what do
you think Austin Powers has so much
chest hair man I'm like to hide the
muscles I had all the muscles
Canadian fit my wife's Canadian so I get
yeah and and and I hadn't really I mean
I owe Lorne and and Mike my comedy
career I mean it does the truth and and
you know in today on Parks and
Recreation there's in a day where I go
by and that said it's all because of
Lauren and it's all because of Mike and
I haven't seen those checks coming my
way lately when Penelope you definitely
made it better than written which is
always what you hope for and you created
such a great atmosphere on set and kill
you and it was just honestly one of my
greatest satisfactions during the making
that film was to see you with the
headset he had to drive in the in the
film but he didn't know how to drive so
his license Naruto we had to give him we
got uh we gave you Sears driving less
yes right yeah very yeah I was staying
at the Four Seasons in Beverly Hills and
it would be your cars here mr. Byers and
it would be the Sears driving school
with a big big giant student driver and
I would be driving and it was this guy
from somewhere but he was just kept
saying I'm praying for you mr. Myers
yeah and we pull up to a light and I was
just starting to get known on the show
and people go hey it's the guy uh one of
us hole okay and [ __ ] you're an
[ __ ] there'd be somebody called me
NASA oh I don't know idea this was going
on to simulate would have brought you an
apple or something